In order to get the most
out of this course,
you should have a good grasp
of Python programming.
If you are comfortable making and
using functions, classes,
dictionaries and understand the basics
of properties, decorators and
lambda functions,
you're in good shape for this course.
A few links for
brushing up on these topics
are available in the instructor notes.
We will be using the Flask
web development framework.
And SQLAlchemy extensively
in this course.
If you're not familiar with the basics
of Flask, please check out the official
Flask documentation or
Udacity's full stack Foundations course.
Links to both of these can also
be found in the instructor notes.
An understanding of OAuth 2
flows will also be very helpful
when it comes to securing our web API.
I highly recommend completing Udacity's
authentication authorization course, or
reading through some of Google's Oauth
2 documentation before attempting this
portion of the course.
I highly recommend using a Vagrant
environment for this course.
Vagrant will allow you to work in a
virtual machine with a shared folder you
can access on your host computer.
This way, if anything accidentally
gets messed up in the vagrant machine,
it won't affect your host machine.
A link to downloading and
installing a Vagrant machine,
pre-installed with all
the necessary libraries for
this course, can also be found
in the instructor notes.
We will be delving into the Google and
FourSquare documentation, and
playing with their APIs
later in this course.
You will need developer accounts for
both of these applications,
which can be created free of charge.
Links for creating these accounts,
if you do not previously have them,
can be found in
the instructor notes as well.